let's go next to a caller from the six
one seven area code caller from six one
seven what's your name where are you
calling from and what's on your mind
today hi my name is Alex I'm from
Needham Massachusetts and I wanted to
talk to you about the giant humanitarian
and political crisis in Venezuela yeah
so their president has been doing giant
power grabs all over the place giving
himself unchecked power arresting
political opponents and it basically
seems to me like they're on the road to
a revolution there so I wanted to get
your take on where you think that whole
situation is headed and what the US and
maybe other countries can do that soften
the crisis they're having
yeah so I talked about this a little bit
earlier in the week and the situation
continues to develop and so to be
totally clear there's as I mentioned
Alex there's a contingent of the left
that is sort of like the apologists for
the Bolivar and revolution meaning Hugo
Chavez and now Nicolas Maduro and a lot
of it has to do with antipathy towards
American foreign policy in Latin America
and they are very quick to say any
opposition is American funded astroturf
and Maduro is actually being framed as
being much worse than he is but as I
mentioned earlier in the week I've been
following media reports from
non-american media in other South
American countries that have been doing
really good investigative reporting and
it's really bad down there it's really
bad down there so the question about
what the u.s. can or should do I don't
know that that's the right question for
me to answer because I don't know that
the u.s. necessarily can or should do
anything they can do things I don't know
that they should whether they're on
their way to a revolution or not I think
is an interesting question you know when
you look at the the bogus nature of
those elections that were called the
arrests of opposition leaders the
intimidation of adversarial press to the
extent that it even exists and it's very
even difficult even to say what that
would be
I believe that Nicolas Maduro is a
disaster I believe that Hugo Chavez was
a disaster I think that this is an
authoritarian
right-wing dictatorship couched as some
kind of left-wing socialist populist
revolution and I don't know why so many
on the left in the United States have
kind of fallen for it but I hope that
Maduro is out sooner than later now that
being said that doesn't necessarily
answer who should go in because there's
no question that the US has played a
role in getting involved with opposition
leaders in Latin America it's often not
gone well so that's a sort of different
question but if you've been following
what's going on with hunger access to
basic food and supplies toiletries a
currency hyper devaluation it's an
absolute and total disaster so I'm
following it really closely Alex all
right thank you all right great to hear
from Alex and Needham I've been to need
him before not too far not too far from
our studio here